foreign
[Music]
Megan to protect Katie from feeling
lonely
she will recognize you as her primary
user and when you do that you're going
to pair with her
crazy it's insane right
Megan your goal is to protect Katie from
harm both physical and emotional
[Music]
I won't let anything harm you I love her
Megan's not a person Katie you don't get
to say that
[Music]
you will be
good
what are you doing couldn't sleep
occupational hazard
what the hell is that
[Music]
you should probably run
I don't let anything harm you ever again
Megan have I done something to upset you
Gemma I know you think you're maximizing
your objective function oh really
[Music]
[Music]
you'd have to shut her down Jesus Christ
I
[Music]
have a new primary user now me
thank you
did make him do something bad
what's going on
[Music]
what are you I'm Megan baby
what is it you like to talk about
my patient
hi I know you're nervous I just want to
have a chat
I'm seeing something no one else can see
except for me it's smiling at me
yesterday a patient in your care died
brutally in front of you
oh I need to find an explanation for
what happened
smiling at me
[Music]
[Music]
you're going tonight you're going to die
yeah
I saw 20 cases involving 19 victims of
the direct line linking them all
together
[Applause]
you said only 19.
why is it that everybody else who's seen
it just dead in your life
I've seen it too
yeah
[Music]
how long between each victim's death
none of them survived longer than a week
today is my fourth day I am not gonna
keep running
face it how does that make you feel
[Music]
all right
I'm just really scared that something
bad is going to happen
[Applause]
[Music]
so did you figure out what you're
dressing up as tomorrow he wants to
dress up as a real guy who murdered nine
people last year oh you're not doing
that
just a costume
you think that guy's still out there
what's up with you and this clown all of
a sudden you're like obsessed they never
found his body what if he decides to
come back here
I wouldn't worry about it wait a minute
aren't you that guy from the costume
shop sir what are you doing it wasn't me
he was covered in blood on his shirt and
his hands when he got here
right down to the little black dot on
the tip of his nose
you're really weird you know that I
believe him about what something really
bad's gonna happen tonight no I know
when Jonathan's lying okay I could hear
it in his voice some things something's
wrong look we're gonna have fun
stress-free environment yep speaking of
surprises kids we have a very special
guest with us today all the way from
Miles County please welcome art the
Clown
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
right
now
oh you've got to be kidding me
yeah this is 476 barbering right yeah
I'm renting this place no I booked it a
month ago are you sure you have the
right place yeah who am I supposed to do
why don't you come inside and we'll call
these idiots
[Music]
why don't you just crash here oh no
I don't know if you've got a great look
at this neighborhood
but I don't think you should be out
there by yourself
it's drying there's a lock on the door
by the way I'm Keith Tess you take the
bedroom and I'll sleep out here on the
couch
[Music]
kiss
me
Keith
[Music]
foreign
this process might seem overwhelming
a little practice
it can soon become
a pleasurable experience
this is Perfectly Natural
foreign
it's really nice
you can hold it
what is it
it's a puzzle
[Applause]
and it's almost finished
keep going
so if I solve it
do I get a prize
I do
[Music]
What's your deal it has six sides six
configurations
it opens up
Cuts you
and then they come to collect
foreign
it's been four years
since Michael Myers vanished Without a
Trace
[Music]
hello
[Music]
I was certain I saw him
watching me
you pretend like you moved on but you're
actually just obsessed with death what
are you gonna do when Michael comes back
for you because he is coming
but this time
something feels different
he's more dangerous
thank you
[Music]
he killed my daughter but tonight I will
kill him come and get me
[Music]
boys
[Music]
maybe the only way he can die is if I
die too it all ends now
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I know it's unusual in this day and age
to devote your life to something
spiritual hey good morning but ever
since my mother's issues I've always
felt a calling to help people
foreign
[Music]
she's not as scary as she looks she can
hear you
you're my favorite person here us girls
we gotta stick together in this place
we have a female student in the class
only as an observer because as you know
women are strictly forbidden from
performing exorcism female surgeons are
once Unthinkable somebody had to be the
first
when you enter the room of the possessed
you are walking onto a Battlefield
strike Terror lowered into the Beast now
defiling this innocent child
I can't hear you no
[Music]
apparently I'm here
you have a gift I'd like to teach you
this relationship it's personal we all
have a personal relationship with God
it's with God
this feeling has followed me my entire
life
you got my invitation
we've been waiting for you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
try that
[Music]
you didn't when the cops get here you
have to be good and gone I can't help
you anymore I know it's not your fault
you were born this way you ate them I
believed you had to I don't know why
foreign
I thought I was the only one
I don't want to hurt anybody famous last
words
are there lots of us I don't actually
meet many others
why'd you have to bring me along you
seem nice I am nice
okay I'm looking for you I smelled you
you could smell me half a mile away
can you do that not that far I got rules
never never ever eat an eater
I thought you might be hungry for hands
no he lives here is there someone dead
up there
[Music]
I'm not gonna be like that we don't have
many options either you eat you off
yourself or you lock yourself up in
there we're dangerous one of us Jake's
teaching me how to smell other eaters
but we can cut one another just as bad
go go go go go go go
it's too much
you gotta do this we have to do it
you've been following me and we got
unfinished business
you don't think I'm a bad person
[Music]
[Music]
good morning ladies and gentlemen I'm
guessing that some of you you're not
happy maybe you don't fit in people make
fun of you well I can't make you
straight
but you give us this week and we might
be able to help
boys cabin over there girls cabin over
there I usually them pronouns as in they
can't believe they're at this camp
I have zero interest in not being gay
there's no judgments in this room
sometimes I wish I was invisible
I would understand it a lot more if
there's Bible thumping and queer bashing
do you even believe in any of this
come in please
do you think your parents are
disappointed in you sometimes so what do
you do you try to make yourself
special you become
they
today we're going to be exploring
traditional gender roles
like how long they've been doing this
it's time to play this could get a lot
worse where's my killer we need to get
out of here taste
just enjoy the sunshine and work on your
tan
day slash them streaming only on peacock
August 5th
I know
what it is you do
there is no time for you
we'll show you the way to the kingdom of
heaven
repent
or you will be left for the final
cleansing
[Laughter]
what are you doing back here are you
okay who's this she's from that weirdo
cold
I think they're gonna leave for heaven
before the rest of us
was that your mother yeah what happened
to her
you want to call this kind of thingy and
it just creates more problems now I just
gotta clean it up are you gonna go home
you can't go home
we have a rule we stay you work but if
you work we take care of you because
it's rough out there
you're good buddy
so I am looking for a little fun
your mind has been poisoned
and I know it is not your fault you are
so beautiful
oh you don't have to be scared I
couldn't hurt a fly
we are here to cleanse ourselves of this
world and then we believe it
[Music]
[Music]
what is he doing here we found your
daughter she's alive
be prepared for changes we have a child
therapist that she'll be working with
four years is a long time what she needs
right now is her family mister
sweetheart it's Mommy
welcome home Esther we left it just as
it was
it's lovely to be back I miss my family
very much
our goal here is helping us to acclimate
back into life within the family unit
[Music]
sorry
I think something's going on with a stir
is there anything you want to tell me
about your time way
how's that possible four years ago she
was still drawing stick figures
Esther's Behavior has been so erratic
hello Mommy
thank you Mommy
I did notice some inconsistencies
what are you getting at to me it felt
like a performance
[Music]
I made it to you
[Music]
the mother protects her family
no matter what
that's the story of
that's the Glory of Love
[Music]
it was always just my mom and me to have
a family that's what I really want
no way I got a cousin that is the
whitest man I've ever seen he wants to
meet up Oliver cousin Evie it sounds so
Jane Austen when you say it like that
you know my mom always wanted to take me
to England to learn about our family
history with his wedding coming up
actually you should come I would love to
but everyone is dying to meet you
[Music]
wow it's incredible
at least this is one of our important
guests Evie this is a close friend of
the family Walter DeVille uh hi hi
looking forward to getting to know you
better
[Music]
what are you doing down there
miss you should return to your room
we're all so delighted that you're here
which one's at the ground the groom and
his brothers will make their grand
entrance tomorrow
ready I I can't shake the feeling that
everyone is staring at me
you and Walter seem to be getting
awfully closely
I'm curious though what has he told you
about us
let me see
here she is where are the bride and
groom
as you all know there has been someone
missing from this table but that once
broken bond will be renewed tonight
to even a new Pride
I want to go home but this is your home
get up in bed good luck
please
hey dear hello Mr Harker here there's a
young lady who seems quite distressed
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
horrible thing happened to you I just
want you to be able to move on with your
life
come here it's coming up on a year I
have something that's planned and I need
a partner in crime the b-67 TV tower I
haven't climbed since Becky if you don't
confront your fears you are always going
to be afraid
let's do it
let's climb your stupid Tower oh I'm so
excited
hey guys
[Music]
I was really ripped you're awesome God
is the Becky that we need for this trip
thank you
this is sick
damn it Andre what are you getting us
into
okay so just stay behind me one wrong at
a time
[Music]
see it's easy
you're doing great
Becca you gotta come up here
hey trust me
what was that
Hunter how do we get down
I don't have a signal
I have water Roost out there in that bag
we have 50 feet of rope
I think I could drop myself lower
okay I'm gonna jump onto this bag
every hour the pass is the weaker we get
if anyone called 9-1-1 we'd be here by
now
what is it that Dan used to say if
you're scared of dying don't be afraid
to live
[Music]
you don't have to be nervous I'm not
nervous well so impressive you're
impressive they're gonna be obsessed
with you
they're not as nihilistic as they look
on the internet you guys this is me oh
whoa this is your first relationship oh
no you just kind of give that Vibe but
you know that has weed in it right
[Applause]
who wants to play body's body
so how do you play
if you draw the piece of paper that has
the X on it you are the murderer let's
go
and if you're the murderer you have to
kill someone by touching them on the
back
the most important part if you come
across a body you have to yell
[Music]
at the lights
our friend is dead
someone is doing this you're trying to
kill us off one by one that would be so
obvious if I were the Killer
let's go oh how long have you known her
what are you talking about
I'm staying safe really
[Applause]
really
[Music]
I brought something what is it it's
zucchini bread yum oh God
[Music]
what if I told you
that today
you'll leave here
I'm talking
to
you
bro
see summon above the clouds that's big
I'll be big
but whatever kill pops is out there
right here
you
are gonna witness an absolute spectacle
[Music]
so what happens next
you ready
[Music]
here we go
it's a real opportunity I'm talking rich
and famous for life there's plenty of
videos for flying [ __ ] online you know
why they gonna get what we gonna get
what we gonna get the money shot what's
up undeniable proof of aliens on camera
the overshot you guys gonna tell me
what's going on hell no
cause I'm now here are you the only
person in the world that can get it on
film
a cloud hey move the net it's aliens
they're just waiting for the perfect
time to shove metal probes up our asses
I'll be rooting for you
I think we pissed them off yeah they
repainted your house
[Music]
they gonna come back
shot
let's go
I need y'all to tell me what did you see
in a cloud
well it's not what you think
he took me
they took them all
I'm trying to save you my brother is out
there I don't think they take you if you
don't look at it
a stream you're chasing
where you end up with the top of the
mountain
it's the one you never wake up from
you'll be getting a call from my
supervisor asking how my service was
damn River assembly second home third
you can count the one we built in
Martha's Vineyard
making their safe just walked in all
right have fun happy New Year Chad hello
there he is there's like a big storm
headed your way all right you guys have
fun don't drink too much on that note I
say more shots okay guys
when do you think the power will come
back on I thought it would be by now
we're not going anywhere
we need to stay as warm as possible
hypothermia can cause bizarre
risk-taking behavior
on the phone
what if the snow is contaminated
you can't spread a virus
the danger is real
please
doesn't a hot shower sound nice
the U.S defense department has spent
over a trillion dollars on the most
cutting-edge robot technology
introducing robosanta Plus for the
upcoming holiday season
where are you gonna do this fine
Christmas Eve I was potentially gonna go
meet up with a dude I blown him off
twice already so come on get a drink
with your old pal Robbie what's up with
YouTube
I saw a crowd of some tender trash you
didn't talk me out of anything
[Applause]
Merry Christmas
new animatronic state of the art Santa
Claus featured at our own TW bunkers is
now the subject of international recall
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you hear that hear what
[Music]
you need to give me a gun
[Music]
oh Santa Claus yeah it's [ __ ] Santa
Claus
oh
oh
have you heard from the boys down at the
scene yet they're still down there
counting bodies
[Applause]
why do you want to hunt
because you all think that I can't
I saw a sign in the sky
I'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
you can't I'm trying to protect you
protect me from what
[Music]
it's time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
good knows how to hunt
I know how to survive
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
whatever did this I can
[Applause]
no one knows how it starts
but when the fear begins when the
paranoia takes over
it makes people do terrible things
good morning as you can see some of you
have chosen to stay home today given
what's been happening
[Music]
Carrick internet character that tells
you to kill people it made this kid stab
his own mother there's a lot of people
freaking out about it nobody knows what
it actually is
foreign
you saw the Grim Cutty yeah like in my
house what is it
[Music]
we've been getting calls about it all
night
how are we supposed to protect our
family
my parents can't see it but when I try
to tell them what I saw it just makes it
more hysterical
foreign
can we start over
and just sit down and I'll talk it out
together
laughs
[Music]
the world
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
I miss you I miss my son well you better
get used to it because you'll never see
either one of us ever again
mother How Could You Scout my number he
just wants to talk to you why don't I
come and stay with David for a while I
don't need any help everything's perfect
[Music]
mom mom there's there's a monster
outside my window
you and I are completely safe like two
bugs snug in a rug
hi doctor I'm wondering if um maybe I
should go back on medication
St Mary's Church
I think I have edema in my house
foreign
[Music]
immigrants gone by election day God I
deported
zero tolerance the da is offering to
drop charges if he volunteers to help
Care for senior citizens
in owl Cove we truly appreciate you
being here to help out our seniors
how am I supposed to be this nasty ass
meatloaf Spiker I suggest you say
something you know because your skin a
Argentinian
you stick to the program your time here
should be pretty fast and easy
sorry
foreign
you really got away with the ladies
[Music]
what are you talking about you trying to
escape
done
I promise you you stick with the program
you're going to leave this place more
mature you may even gain a newfound
appreciation for life
you okay
just feeling breathing
am I in here because I'm Latino or black
how about
[Music]
please Lord make me the biggest star the
world has ever known so that I'll make
it far far away from this place not
caring for your family during these
times is admirable
on taking this life if only they would
just die
pardon
nothing
[Applause]
I want to be special dancing up on the
screen let the pretty girls in the
pictures
I will not let you leave this Farm again
come on
I'm worried there may be something real
wrong with me rumor has it they only
take one gal her town
we're looking for someone with X Factor
has to be
about a film nobody else has seen
will be eventually
I know what I've done
bad things
terrible awful murderous thing
I want to be loved from as many people
as possible
but truth is I'm not really a good
person
you ever heard of Creeper
a local Legend right
the creeper comes back every 23 years
then what
[Music]
I can't believe I let you drag me
this is the Coachella of Cosplay
a grand prize
an escape room for two
come on YouTube
are you sure this is where we're
supposed to be
we'll be out there in no time
[Music]
[Music]
what the hell is that
it's coming
it's a trap
there's no way out
come on
all right all right well I gotta say
that is
very handsome client why didn't you step
me up with him you deserve someone nice
[Music]
Cherie Ethan
that's me
[Music]
I thought you would appreciate the best
sushi in L.A wondering
the only thing that matters now is our
game
you are a marked woman now
he can smell you
[Music]
if you want to survive his game
or the only person who can help you
is a Survivor I need to lay low tonight
how are you surviving now huh
no one beats him he's like a monster
what are you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this Halloween
we can't escape the shock the terror of
werewolf by night tonight it is every
Hunter for themselves good luck I'll be
rotting for you
but one of you is a monster
masquerading as one of our own
can't wait to find out what breed of
evil you are
[Music]
[Applause]
please don't do this
death is coming for you
foreign
[Music]
would you like to see a magic trick yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it doesn't work
hang it up
I made you some breakfast what'd you put
in that
salt and pepper
have you seen this boy my brother he was
taken I may have a black balloons
I had a dream about it
please let the dreams be real
you're getting out of here huh there's a
combination lock what's the combination
you're gonna use a weapon
[Music]
you are special Vinnie
please hurry
oh the creepiest damn thing
[Music]
okay that is new glad you guys are still
finding ways to spice things up we're
leaving in five okay
are the amazing
group shot I kind of wanted to save this
prize but whatever I'll tell you guys
now it's a smart house so I'll send you
guys a link
okay let's do this
now you guys are excited told you I'd
come through wow
Andrew Collins you go by Drew right
welcome home
I've been designed and programmed to
cater to your every need so she's like
the house or what most people just call
me Marco
Kitty now go explore
[Music]
I have quite the weekend in store for
you
what is this this entire place is one
gigantic 3D printer
don't tell me you can't handle this
is something I've been working on for a
long time
it could be out of these
I've never seen AI this Advanced
I mean I can't wait to show you what
outside
who wants to party
but we haven't reach the climax yet
foreign
flowers the perks of real flowers
bad is it it's not that bad
[Music]
[Applause]
follow the heroes not the zero keep up
we need to find weapons if you get us
killed I'm gonna be so pissed what do
you suggest me dude I say draw them to
one side of the building and then slip
through the other
I'm in DND level 20 raw wizard protect
us
what is it with you shut-ins and zombie
fantasy we're not in the goddamn comic
book okay whoa watch the Dolce
is she dead
of course he's dead right he just went
off the freaking room
what we need is fire
really dude
[Music]
is it that bad uh more like badass
watch out watch out
wow I wonder he lives here
you sure this gift's empty
thank God hello
oh what's going on
last night you made the unfortunate
mistake of breaking into my ancestral
home
don't worry this is not an execution
there's the sport in that good luck
why did you let us go why did they wish
us luck
what's that
it's a fox hunt
so what do you hunting
[Music]
people are gonna find out about this
about what
foreign
Hardy and you're watching Dan Carr
Another Day in Paradise
hello listen I just need you to take my
friends somewhere nearby
this is Angela her and I taking a trip
did you find me
ah
you should guys
hello hello
she's here
hey what was that oh my God oh my God oh
my God
look again
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Evita
Tom I know you're trying your best
spit on him your mom would have been
proud of you but I don't think she'd
feel the same way about the Focus right
now
you ready
[Music]
what what was that
[Music]
we were just playing slap face
[Music]
what happened
did you see it
I could walk down a bowling lane come
back here Pig not far from where you
guys are at
look at something
we do terrible things
we can't help ourselves
it's like good witchcraft I never wonder
what he does with himself and where he
goes
you don't get it it's something just for
us personally I gotta know are you good
or evil
she doesn't eat up the bad kids
she's their friend
[Music]
foreign
we're still trying to figure out what
happened
[Music]
when did you last hear from her
she left to bring her to school
is everything okay
should I missing before not in a long
time
foreign
[Music]
I heard about your mom is she all right
hey it doesn't feel right
I think we should go away just two of us
I think you should take it easy at the
moment mom
where did you go
oh yeah
foreign
there's things I need to tell
it's not your mother up there if we
don't do something we'll never get her
back
and then they'll try to take you
dance with me shark
and I'm stopped
Hey where's your mom
[Applause]
[Music]